because I'm bad sorry
what is up a reject nation happy Monday
hope you had a safe weekend I do too
the Batman 2021 trilogy breakdown a new
Batman villain Easter eggs is he working
out who cares this is from the channel
emergency awesome
I don't know what this is about but
people recommend it so let's check it
out before that though I do want to say
that one and fosston start us that mofos
over there we're doing 30-second reviews
for films TV shows and trailers catch it
up on so much free to use you can post
to pull things entirely free I couldn't
pay to say this we just do it
join us
[Music]
Michael guacamole is such a good
composers is gonna be my new Batman
video Warner Brothers just dropped a
whole bunch of details we also have
future plans for the trilogy itself in
some of the really big characters so
we'll break it down if you're new to the
channel be sure to subscribe to get all
the videos will do a new Amazon giveaway
all you have to do to enter is be
subscribed is this from the actual movie
looks like you didn't see the news
recently the rap reported that because
of the overwhelming success of the Joker
movie with Joaquin Phoenix made over a
billion dollars secretly behind the
scenes DC movies were planning to do a
new more comic book accurate version of
the Bane character in his own DC Black's
gonna be a rush let me see it wouldn't
be Tom Hardy's version of Bane to be a
completely different actor they didn't
say who because of scheduling problems
then later said he would love to play
the new version of Bane inside Robert
Pattinson trilogy that's why you've been
seeing all that fan art of him is Bane
he definitely looks like he could pull
apart a comic book Bane even if they
didn't use special effects they can look
eight feet tall but he's tripping out on
the venom serum if you're really gonna
go for a conical accurate Bane but
apparently one in the better of the
little while ago DC decided not to do
the full blown Bane solo movie treatment
DC Black Label mostly because there are
a billion more famous Batman villains to
do DC black label movies about as you
would expect why would they go with
their bigger more popular characters
first this all makes sense and to don't
because number picture guys my scarecrow
idea isn't gonna do the Bane movie also
because they decided to shuffle a new
version of Bane into the robber patent
oh really in one of the sequels but just
to be clear Bane is not in the new
Batman movie that's coming in is gonna
be this nobody cared movie made over a
billion dollars in changed the way you
think about the Joker character you
think DC's first thought would be to
cross him over with the Batman trilogy
the director of The Joker movie Todd
Phillips was asked about this throughout
last year during the Joker press to her
and his answer was always that he made
the Joker movie with the specific intent
that it was his own thing off in its own
universe and that was part of the reason
why Warner brother
let him do it rated R Robert Pattinson
was cast as Batman I know this is a
totally different movie but but I'm
talking about the part two there's some
age difference issues between Joaquin
Phoenix's Joker and Robert apparently be
no more than 10 to 15 years older than
Batman in Joaquin Phoenix is in his 50s
even with D aging technology the Joker
movie was supposed to take place in the
early 80s so it's just too much of a
stretch and I'm not on board with the
theory that his Joker inspired the real
comic book Joker that you see fighting
Batman I still think that he is meant to
be the Joker so number three right now
Matt Reeves has said that he doesn't
introduce a new version of the Joker
during the first Batman movie but they
will do him at some point during the
sequels he will come up he's just too
big of a character to completely swerve
on during this new trilogy most like
Joker sequel movie Todd Phillips and
Joaquin Phoenix's most recent statements
about doing a Joker sequel are more
along the lines of we're not in any rush
to do it but maybe we'll do it someday
which means if it does have Batman
villains so number two there was also a
recent report that Warner Brothers
intended to use Robert Pattinson new
Batman trilogy to set up potential third
- and the backers and there are some
recent after comments that corroborate
this in the first new Batman movie next
year we know we're getting the Penguins
the Riddler Catwoman and carmine Falcone
it should go without saying even if you
stand carmine Falcone as a character
there pleye not gonna give him a solo
movie but Colin Farrell who's claimed
the penguin please Lee said that he
doesn't have much to do in this first
new bat Westminster
with his scenes can we say that you're
playing the penguin in the movie yeah
yeah yeah yeah it's definitely cookies
we wouldn't even show yes but the
penguin it surprises me that you are the
penguin because usually the penguin is a
short fat person Yeah right some time to
eat Matt Reeves who's the director who
wrote the script a really really
beautiful dark yeah yeah with a you know
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Music]
is the Riddler yeah he's trying to talk
about gender right zoe kravitz yeah
wound up in the daredevil movie and then
in Batman movies but that Alliance that
he's made since then while they were
actually working on the film sort of
corroborate the idea that Warner
Brothers is thinking about doing a DC
black label movie at some point in the
future with his penguin character why
would you cast something as big as Colin
Farrell and Pam all that money first was
a huge event film the Batman movies then
barely use him in any scenes they can I
do it all the time
I don't know just post your best theory
about what you would call that in the
comments a bad first but it's the same
deal with the Riddler the Catwoman to
face once they debut a new version of to
face in the Batman movies because number
one there's also a new rumor that says
they're trying to get Matthew
McConaughey as their new to face in the
Batman sequel whoa
really you can play you can play
superhero movies both Marvel and DC all
around is it they rarely do a good job
at developing all of their villain
characters especially films that have
multiple villains in them the Joker
movie with Joaquin Phoenix basically
solved that problem so you see all these
big Batman villains show up in the new
Robert Pattinson Batman trilogy but you
get the deep character study with each
of them in their potential solo movies
depending on how everything works out
and if things are successful if we're
talking about which order they would do
those solo movies in I'd rather see the
Riddler or Sarah brother first then do
the other one and then once they cast
their new version of two-face do his
solo movie then after whatever the last
rubber Pattinson Batman movie winds up
being then you do your Catwoman solo
movie because and there are a couple of
sequel stories to the long Halloween
there's Batman dark victory which they
could use as the plot for the sequel to
the Robert Pattinson Batman movie then
there's the Haunted Knight and there's
also a story called Catwoman When in
Rome which takes place concurrently with
one of those other stories they always
use that is the story for the Catwoman
solo movie though but you get the idea
Warner Brothers seems like it's trying
to construct a new cinematic universe
through this new Batman trilogy which i
think is kind of funny so just to be
clear Robert Pattinson --zz Batman isn't
meant to be connected to Justice League
or be a prequel to Ben Affleck's Batman
we do have the flash movie coming up
they're doing a version of flashpoint
you want to use that to connect him but
no Justice League if they really do want
to bring everything together for a
Justice League - they're gonna
time-travel and release it on this
property it doesn't really matter
but we have this Snyder cut coming up
but that's not meant to be a sequel to
the first Justice League it's meant to
replace the original Justice League
movie I've heard have done a bunch of
Justice League's miter-cut videos so
I'll link those at the end of this but
that's all completely separate from
what's going on with
Batman movies and Robert Pattinson so
there was some confusion about what's
going on with Ben Affleck coming back to
do Snider cut stuff that's mostly to do
additional voiceover dialogue he's not
fully coming back as Batman but if we
get any other news in a couple months
this summer so we should start to get
more news about it pretty soon everyone
click here for that Justice League
Snider cut teaser trailer and click here
for my new spider-man 3 in venom 2 video
thank you so much for watching everyone
stays safe I'll see you guys tonight
awesome there's plenty to talk a bucket
when they said Bane movie solo spin-off
like I could see a version if you're
gonna go for like your very realistic
version like the venom serum thing just
wouldn't work but you know like Dark
Knight Rises had a Tom Hardy's Bane in
it and there was no venom serum in it
he's naturally got that way you know
yeah they they have any purpose that you
know iconography for something different
so that you were able to at least keep
some semblance of venom yeah yeah but
you couldn't do again in a different way
yeah Bane's background is completely
different than it is in the Dark Knight
Rises you could have some real you know
rich stuff to explore there I would love
to see like an actual Bane movie yeah I
mean I wouldn't I wouldn't mind it the
idea of Dave Bautista being Bane that's
one of those choices that is obvious but
I love it you know because I he could
really pull that off I constantly flash
to huh flash huh I constantly go to his
little performance that he had oh we had
a question on patreon about a best small
performance in the film and this could
have definitely qualified rate one if
it's the best one but it's a great one
they Bautista's work in Blade Runner
2049 like that little scene has so much
gravitas so much weights like one scene
that he has the film it's so early on
but leave such a lasting impact you know
a lot of us associate him in terms of
the film community with Drax he could do
a great Bane he really could well yeah
and I think it's one of those things
where you know he could do it we've seen
him play characters that are physically
similar to that sure haven't seen him do
that flavor of performance yeah you have
that Blade Runner performance but it is
more subdued and Bane would obviously be
a bit more formidable using and dark I
mean I don't know if he'd do like an
accent for Bane but that's why we care I
mean if we're looking for like the most
accurate of depictions leave your fan
cast down perhaps yeah but in terms of
these solo villain movies there's a part
of this report that's a little bit
confusing I know that this is all rumors
but this seems like very likely to you
know at least be heavily considered but
Warner Brothers wants to do considering
the success of top Phillips Joker movie
of doing these solo villain films
there's a couple of them that I think
could really wifey like Catwoman done
properly
hey great solos yeah let's do for a redo
I mean I feel like most of them honestly
could some of them have more
supernatural powers III Bowie I've
thought it would been really cool to do
a scarecrow Jonathan crane origins movie
actually I pitched the whole thing on a
movie fights episode yeah yeah mine
would be a psychological horror film
inspired by Carrie but I would be
focusing on the character of Jonathan
crane aka the Scarecrow and if you look
into the Jonathan cranes bag there's
different versions of course but there's
very much similarities to Jonathan
cranes backstory with Carrie in a lot of
ways actually so mine would take place
in the 1970s and I would focus on
Jonathan crane in senior year of high
school he's someone who is a completely
introverted type of science nerd he gets
made fun of a lot not just for his
demeanor and the way comes across before
the fact of how he has a sort of this
unusual body features kind of like
Ichabod Crane he so he's getting bullied
a lot basically yeah he also deals a lot
with body shaming which is something
that I don't actually see really done
with male young male characters and
movies a lot I think would be cool to
explore that borrowing sort of that
theme from Carrie as well in my version
he'd also be a closeted homosexual
character who has a crush on one of the
football players one of the only
characters is actually nice to him but
the deeper rooted issues with Jonathan
crane would be that at home his father
who was a biology scientist his father
is traumatized from being someone who
wasn't able to save his wife aka
Jonathan cranes mother from a fire he's
working on a developing a cure for fear
borrowing from the comic
the father's developing a cure for fear
and this is doing two fold one fold is
that with similar to carry were these
philosophies become an abusive form he
is developing this because he thinks
fear is the enemy and also he believes
that if he can have his son overcome the
fear he can finally become a man and
stand up for himself link that in the
description below the right timecode
when that starts and he goes to high
school with Bruce Wayne a movie would
make a ton of sense too because more
yeah horror but also like the concept of
fear is something that is intrinsic to
Batman in general and Batman is like a
light side or at least the more
benevolent side of embracing and using
fear constructively whereas the
scarecrow side is destructive yeah if
your mo del Toro to do it yes wants to
make the change well I was kind of
confused of what they were talking about
though in terms of there's possibly
talking about doing these DC black
labels for hangman of Kong Ferrell's so
is the idea if I'm understanding this
correctly is the idea to put Colin
Farrell in like the Batman movies but
then do his own spin-off movie that's in
the DC black label which would then
connect that did Joaquin Phoenix's okay
is that what they're doing here maybe
think todd phillips has said i feel like
at least and it's warner brothers choice
i'm sure at the end of the day but
nothing's gonna connect a joker if they
have their way and i think that's
appropriate what what i got from that is
the idea that maybe they're gonna
feature these villains in the batman
movies and have that be like the group
continuity or something like that and
then do side movies for characters like
okay we've seen a little bit of penguin
in the batman so let's do like a full-on
penguin movie and then maybe make him
even bigger character in the sequel to
the batman or something that that's kind
of what i thought they were getting at I
think they should hold off on Joker for
part 3 they should hold off on Joker for
a while the idea is as a solid trilogy
as what Matt Reeves has in mind and I
really think building up to get Joker in
part 3 would be your best bet to get
some distance and some space from Joker
but also just as fun movie trivia Batman
89 first Batman movie in
that franchise was Jose Joker Dark
Knight's second movie in that franchise
and then you get Joker here third movie
in this franchise and a cool way to
build up to him and maybe like allude to
his presence within Gotham because if
you have all these other people around
right yeah yeah it's like allude to the
fact that Joker exists but then don't
actually have him to a part three that
way the air cut can come out and more
people can like Jer Leto's Joker then
you can put them in place for him
alright but you know that could be cool
too because you could build up you could
create a different dynamic for Batman
where it's like ok here is a movie or
two where he deals with villains who
have some kind of ideology and then you
cap it off with what if you're facing
somebody whose whole ideology is just to
destroy ideology yeah you know so I
think that could be a really cool
dramatic bill that also if he aged he's
gonna age with the Rowlf they keep
Robert Pattinson and so to see him as an
older Batman go up against Joker you
know that would be pretty cool too
honestly if they're if they're planning
doing spin-offs I feel like that our
best bet is instead of introducing them
in these movies but to kind of just put
them in between and then put them in the
movies that's usually when you have so
many of these guys in the movies yes so
many of them that way you don't have to
worry about like they're not really
flushed out in this movie there's too
many villains you you deal where you get
away with that if you have their spit
offs in between right like that just
makes sense it sounds maybe like that's
what they might do with penguin cuz what
I have got out of this is that you know
the first Batman movie is gonna mainly
have the Riddler be the villain and
you're gonna have you know little
moments with penguin so maybe they'll do
that maybe they'll tease penguin I think
oh here's the penguin movie to really
make you understand but I hate this guy
I'm in the sequel we'll make him the
main one to face with Matthew
McConaughey that would be an excellent
casting choice he could easily I like I
don't know how easily I don't feel like
he works really hard his job right you
could definitely pull that off her okay
yeah I hate you play District Attorney
Harvey Dent and he could play two-face
he could do both undoubtably he's
another one of those casting choices
where I'm like it's not the exact
obvious role I've seen him do I just
know he can do it made him for the roles
that he's tackled in recent years
you do the darkness 100% yeah and he
could do the charming mobster like
character as well I would love to see
that actually occur like I hear that I
don't like I can't get that outta my
head now I have like Matthew McConaughey
is like perfect choice ooh
the gentleman means true detective yeah
pretty much
over this vanity footage is yeah very
convincing
thanks thanks to Cosmopolis for
providing all those images of Robert
Pattinson in a suit all right guys which
part of this news excites you the most
thanks emergency Austin for putting this
together make sure to subscribe to the
homeboys channel subscribe to the real
rejects click our notification ball down
low defaults on the start list up last
but not least Andrew Hayes my buddy my
friend
so Andrew made me a really happy camper
recently I rarely hear from this
gentleman he messaged me hey Greg
well more like hey Greg hey Greg I
started the show Barry on HBO because of
you I love it I think he's done with the
show now oh well I was already fully
caught up and he started because of my
heavy heavy recommendation only yours I
mean it was me
really convincing the [ __ ] out of the
guy he like I eat came out of the
Woodworks in order to tell me that he
watched it cuz of me your life changer
so really Andrew I wanted to show you on
this video to tell you how great I am
recommending shows I hope you're being
safe right now in New Jersey I hope that
with your families lock company you're
locking as many doors as possible to
protect yourselves be safe you stay
classy and also tell me how that wedding
goes this is still on have you been cast
as Wolverine yet thanks John